so you know how little baby has one of
those apes on his neck yes
if you want me to be like that for v
friends and to just have a [ __ ]
puffin on my face or something like this
little puffin i got some real estate
right here i can see that being like a
cool look
that would be a tremendous priority of
mine
i'll talk to your whole team about it
yeah
so for the record when they said you're
gonna have some time to talk to garyvee
i'm like all right i gotta dig in try to
figure out as much stuff as possible
that i can give him [ __ ] about i wanted
to hate on you for the nft thing
especially just given where the market
is at right now by the time i got done
watching a couple of podcasts with you i
was like all right
if there is an nft that i'm gonna [ __ ]
with aside from the crypto punk which i
already own i was very impressed by the
v friends thing because i see that you
actually have a road map like a real
game plan for how you're gonna continue
to build the value of these in the long
term which i don't have that assurance
about almost any of the other nfts i've
seen well i'm sure if you did your
homework you start
to your point you probably walked into
some buzz saws which is in every [ __ ]
interview i gave for the entire last 15
months i'm like 99 of this [ __ ] is going
to zero 99
of this is going to zero on the flip
side to your point i'm also looking for
people that look like me i'm a 25 years
in a row
gangster operating [ __ ] entrepreneur
this is what i do
i build actual businesses period it is
what it is you like it you don't like it
it's the truth i know how to [ __ ]
operate which is why you felt that and
actually knowing you and knowing how you
operate it does kind of weird me out
when i watch certain youtube videos
where they're talking about you like
you're
i'm not gonna say any names maybe these
are some people that you know or have
done business with but there's some very
very scammy personalities that it's a
whole identity these days to basically
just be a huckster and just be selling
some [ __ ] all the time i don't feel
like a lot of people on youtube that
i've seen give you a hard time really
understand the depth of how much real
business you've done and i'm empathetic
to that to your point like if you're out
there you have this i have this people
have this if you're out there especially
in today's society you're gonna have you
know shots fired at you i'm empathetic
when people decide to make [ __ ] and try
to go at me that they haven't spent 50
hours like who the [ __ ] am i to have
somebody spend 50 hours to cross every t
and i to realize wait a minute even
though i have a lot of high energy and i
might look the part to them that under
the hood there's some real ass [ __ ] they
weren't in a room where you and i were
in four years ago where we spent two
hours really talking about your
operations they don't know that part of
me and honestly i'm not like my feelings
don't get hurt
like
like the truth is always gonna win out
it's gonna be what it's gonna be
everybody who's [ __ ] on dwayne the rock
johnson that he couldn't go to hollywood
and make it has to eat crow everybody
who [ __ ] on marky mark when he tried to
be mark wahlberg had to eat it did you
buy in early on the rock
what did you buy him at
what were shares going for at that time
i
wasn't paying attention when he made
that transition
but he's [ __ ] when i think about the
rock kevin hart and ryan reynolds they
all sit in the same shelf in my head
which is they're famous as [ __ ] but they
work like such [ __ ] dogs and they're
you know like you know what i mean like
those guys are like actual entrepreneurs
comma they have talents and other fame
right hundred percent
um okay but so the the big thing like
especially these other way to get some
flowers while i'm sitting with you what
you're like well i'll give it to you
because
for you
early on when we when we chopped up
years ago and i was doing my homework
i'm like man this guy's this guy works
it's a very big part of my first
pass-through whip test is somebody
actually working or are they trying to
make something happen quick just the
amount of content interviews the way you
interviewed
like the operations of the store i'm
like oh this guy [ __ ] works i hate to
let you down though like i felt like
this is the year where i finally
realized like okay
you've been doing this [ __ ] for a long
ass time you've made a lot of [ __ ]
money you can afford to take a week off
here a week there go on you know just
in terms
by the way that's not disappointing that
makes me proud
but spending time with the kid makes you
have to consider that [ __ ] you know of
course a lot of things dude family a
life event you could lose an uncle and
be like you looked up to and be like
[ __ ] i don't want to end up like that
things happen by the way i take plenty
of personal time i go hard when i'm in
it when i'm on the field i go hard but
you know that's not what i meant by work
i didn't mean and i didn't know and i
don't even know right now that you were
going 19 hours every day
it wasn't that it was the amount of
output you were putting out and the
interviews i watched they were
thoughtful you weren't even what you
just said right now even if you want to
make it as a razz you're like let me go
do a little work
you put in work a lot of people don't
put in work adam they don't or they put
in a lot of work for a little while and
that's fine everybody's got different
ambitions everybody can have their thing
but you put it you put in work i respect
that that is what it takes for sure okay
but so how do you
separate yourself in a world where i
think we both agree that 99 of nfts have
basically turned out to be scams you're
almost not even seeing new ones at the
same rate that you used to how do you
solve the ultimate question in this day
and age which is like i'm in the nfc
business but i'm not a scammer and i
believe that this [ __ ] has long term
value what are the most important things
to communicate to the audience
i think this is really interesting i
think most people try to convince
and i believe in just having conviction
meaning in 1998 when this had the reason
i knew it was going to happen is because
i saw it when i was a kid with internet
stocks
everybody was so hyped about the
internet that every internet company was
worth a grillion and they sucked
and that's what happened here the nft
thing is gonna happen
but in the gold rush of the first year
there's a lot of that greed and [ __ ]
right what happened in 98.99 2000 was
paypal amazon and ebay
they just [ __ ] worked they just made
real companies they just waited they ate
their [ __ ]
they were sad
they were patient
that you know i'm sure they got called
i'm sure jeff bezos to his face was said
your scam and a fad because all these
internet stocks just crashed he and his
mind said i don't think so let me go to
work i'll see you in 2010 for the one to
two percent out there right now that
really believe they're building
something meaningful and they're getting
caught up in the mockery they got to
shut their mouth put their [ __ ]
helmet on go to work and pop up in 2037
and say i told you you do not know how
to build a business around the
intellectual property you have no shot
and
and
and a lot of that has to do with real
life access
has to do with events has to do with
virtual access
to your point i'm going more of a
pokemon transformers gi joe my little
pony route yeah um but there's a lot of
ways to use the blockchain most people
don't even understand the blockchain yet
they don't really understand what's
actually happening
and
you know i think this is a great
conversation i'll be honest with you i'm
relieved that we're finally in this
chapter
the last the last 15 months have been
anxious to me because i knew that this
was going to happen and as much as the
content as i put out to your point
it's people didn't hear that part so is
this almost a relief
seeing the market sort of cleanse itself
of all this [ __ ] you always want the
market to be healthy and the market is
never healthy when it's over evaluated
or grossly underevaluated and overvalued
it's even more scary because people that
buy lottery tickets are the same people
that look into these projects there's a
desperation there's a i like a quick
buck there's a it's too good to be true
and when you when you're that person
you're lacking patience
you have you have insecurity you're
looking for something to fill a void and
you're you're you're grasping at straws
and you get caught and that sucks if
disney drops nfts for you know mickey
mouse and donald duck and all this [ __ ]
and the star wars characters and [ __ ]
like that if you see disney and nintendo
and all these big companies who own all
this amazing ip if they drop all of
their characters as nfts is that a good
thing or a bad thing for the friends
it's not an if it's a win
[Music]
uh it's a it's a non-event for be
friends
meaning
to your point
i already know it's it when
i don't need i don't need
disney or nintendo or pokemon's
validation
they've already been flirting with
digital goods a lot to begin with and
most of all the world's abundant so even
if they come in they rightfully
deservingly for what they've done for
the last 50 years will be monster market
share they should be
like donald duck should be
um and pikachu should be uh zelda should
be
and
that would be great but that's not gonna
you know it's kind of the way i think
about the world the reason i cheer for
everyone
is because nobody's winning is coming
out of my winnings
this is not how the world works but
doesn't it make the v friends seem a
little less special like 10 years from
now do you think the most interesting
thing about the v friends is going to be
that they were initially funded by nft
drop i think it will be
yes i think i think similar but check
this out yes and no for example i don't
know if everybody here thinks the most
interesting thing about transformers and
he-man is is that they started as
cartoons after school i think it's
interesting because i'm a business nerd
i realized in the 80s after school
television created a bunch of big ips
you know
for me it will be to you know to to
rescind my answer probably not if for
business people that are being
thoughtful it will be
but
you know for me
again
if i do what i need to do
it's going to be relevant
of anything else that's happening
because people are going to give a [ __ ]
about empathy elephant or patient panda
because i made them not because of the
timing or it was nfts and i plan on
doing that if in 20 years the garyvee
factor
seems like it's not that big a deal
that's a great thing for the vip right
by the way that's my preference i i say
a lot that i want to convert from being
mickey mouse and hulk hogan
to being vince mcmahon and walt disney i
you know there's a lot of [ __ ] that i
have that i want to say to the world
but i recognize that garyvee me i'm
limited there's a lot of people that
[ __ ] with me there's a lot of people
that will never [ __ ] with me because i'm
a single human being with a certain
communication style and i am who i am
my 275 characters i can push [ __ ]
account i'll give an example i think
most of the people's anxiety in this
room and the world is because people
don't want to be accountable
and when you're not accountable you
blame everybody else
so for me i can say that a hundred
thousand times but the fact that i can
make a countable ant into an extremely
popular children's book series and now
seven-year-olds are like
accountability's cool like i can [ __ ]
do what the [ __ ] i want adam and that's
i think about it that way
definitely 100
uh what would you say to people who have
taken a real ass beating over the last
week or so in the crypto market
what's your advice like you know should
they still keep chasing these dreams or
for a lot of people obviously they've
been irresponsible you only lose when
you sell
sometimes you lose when you don't sell
too right
all those luna holders ksi and his three
million dollars with a luna he seems
like he lost he didn't sell to your
point you know if you look at the entire
marketplace
luna
ha and i'm undereducated on
cryptocurrencies i actually own only
bitcoin in currencies and then i really
understand nfts because of the
collectible [ __ ] so i don't [ __ ] with
currencies but my understanding from my
currency friends is luna had a value
proposition that they promised that
became
exposed to not be true and so 100 of the
confidence went away
a lot of coins are out there that have
declined they didn't have the extremity
of what happened with luna again i don't
like to talk about [ __ ] i don't know so
that's my very far away headline reading
hypothesis i heard from some friends but
for the rest of the crew that are
getting smashed on their solana they
bought for 200 now it's 50. or ethereum
you paid 4 000 and now it's 1900. or
bitcoin you paid 60 and now it's 30. in
that world if you bought it because you
believed in it
well why would you sell it when others
don't
and that to me is the punchline of this
whole thing you only lose on your
convictions when you sell
if you didn't actually have conviction
and you were just [ __ ] following for
the moment where you were looking to
make a quick dollar right and so i would
tell them to be patient if you believed
in the [ __ ] hold on
do you think i should sell my crypto
punk
i don't
you know to me i believe nfts are here
forever nfts like the internet in 98.
i've thought that 98 back to what you
saw i was right on that i think crypto
punk's out of everything including the
friends and i believe in myself the most
has a very different sitting in the
whole game it is the project that
[ __ ] created this game
[Music]
in 50 years when this is a thing
the historians are gonna go back and
they're gonna be like that one
ford ape has to be kith supreme
vape for 20 years to justify their value
be friends i have to go out and actually
build pokemon to justify the value
world of women has to do that cool cats
doodles moon birds with kevin rose they
have to go out and execute for a decade
properly just to [ __ ] be valued about
what they are now right punks
doesn't have to do nothing history
that's what really sold me on in the
beginning and i didn't really understand
that when you look at the friends or the
or the apes
that
working to build the ip would be the
other thing that could set an nft apart
correct the crypto punks are
automatically scarce because they have
this legacy of being so history yeah
it's history it's set up the whole game
the one of the rarest things in crypto
punks is an eight like that sport like
like it is the game the reason people
collect aliens and zombies and apes in
like every collection that happened in
2021 is because of punk's providence
which was a word thrown around a lot in
the beginning of nft 2020 2021 that's
disappeared in this gold rush greed
phase will come back people will start
looking at the history of the game and i
think things in 20 on ethereum 2017 1819
projects will have a different floss
than the ship like v friends and others
that popped off in the next chapter
those projects me included have a lot of
[ __ ] work to do when you look at the
apes though are you are you kind of in
awe of how
massively executed their marketing has
been
so cheer for them heavy pumped for them
you know they're
when i look at that one i'm like you
know with me i'm like oh i'm lucky i get
to run a marathon to build a pokemon in
disney they're so built on cool and you
know this because you [ __ ] with
culture street culture pop culture hip
hop culture brand culture
[ __ ] staying on top as a fashion
brand
is hard
like who's rocking supremes here today
well i did see one of our filmers has it
on his beanie but that's just one you
know what i mean
six years ago right
you know like palace kip
that's a [ __ ] hard-ass game
and so but but it happens look at this
nike's done it like he's done it for 40
years so for me i'm cheering for apes to
do it for 40 years but they've got a lot
of work to do like all of us in
different ways but yeah i'm very
impressed i love it guy oh siri somebody
i've known in business for a long time
he's heavily involved with them so i i
i've met one or two of the founders in
the early days of of this whole world
who chopped it up in those early days i
have seven board eights that might you
know so i'm i'm cheering for them heavy
so you know how little baby has one of
those apes on his neck yes
if you want me to be like that for v
friends and to just have a [ __ ]
puffin on my face or something like this
little puffin i could i got some real
estate right here i could see that being
like a cool look
that would be a tremendous priority of
mine
i'll talk to your whole team about it
yeah
what about like when you see them just i
don't know what the back end deal is
with it or anything but when they're
like oh man look at eminem has this
board ape now do you look at that and
you're like that's a brilliant marketing
idea but do you feel like that's not on
brand for the v friends or how do you
think about that kind of celebrity
endorsement
i'm concerned i was concerned about this
first 15 months
so i took it slow and steady
in this first chapter because i knew
that it could be great for the short
term
but it created potential vulnerability
for the long term
i knew that i could have went out and
biz dev with a lot of people i know
but i would but i want people to buy
a v friend
because they actually want to hold it
forever not because it's of the moment
or they bought it to flip
i have no sense of what
any a-list celebrity has done or why
they went in or why they bought or why
they changed their profile picture
you know how things happen something
becomes a movement and just happens some
of them just did it because other
celebrities did it some did it because
they believe it's a great investment
some people did it because they got a
short-term marketing deal everyone does
it for different reasons i didn't want
to do too much
in the first
chapter which we're getting out of right
now because i knew there would be too
much emotion and too much mockery and so
i'm just focused on you know vcon coming
up this weekend in minnesota seven eight
thousand people
huge event
really excited about it uh focused on
making that epic i was focused on series
two because i had to really
get the characters from my doodles into
the creation form of how i was going to
build the ip
listen you know this about me adam i'm a
businessman that happens to live on
social and do [ __ ] so i've been in
businessman mode the first year and a
half
i'll i'll i'll do the tortoise game like
i'm going to win this race in the end i
know it i know who i am and i really
don't even look at it as a race against
other projects i just know what it takes
to build something meaningful and i'm
willing to do it slower and meaningfully
not that i'd be i mean listen i want
every [ __ ] a b c d list celebrity and
human being on earth to [ __ ] buy a
beef and put in their account it's just
not the thing that i'm most focused on
in chapter
um another question let me pull it on
you yeah flip it on me
what has been your journey in these four
in these 12 to 14 months on nft like
this looks [ __ ] crazy oh my god this
is legit [ __ ] wait is this a scam like
how is give me your roller coaster so
initially i was trying to be open-minded
about it learning as much as i possibly
could i listened to a podcast with a
poker player named doug polk that
basically convinced me that the crypto
punks were going to be a very good
long-term investment i got my girl to go
in half with me on one we went to buy it
at 80k by the time we had figured out
how to transfer the money and everything
it was 160k at one point i think it was
450k for the floor which ours is
approximately at the floor i believe i'm
not sure what it would be uh right now
120. okay yeah i i had a moment where i
was really thinking long and hard about
doing a no jumper like series of nfts
where there would be a limited number
created for each interview that i did i
ended up running into the problem of
like i don't own any of these people's
likenesses and it would be like
unspeakably difficult to get permission
to use especially for interviews that
i've done five six years ago you know am
i gonna get permission to use little
peeps face for five nfts it just didn't
really make sense to me
looking at it now i am also concerned
like wow that would be tough to uh
convince the world that i was uh on the
up and up in that regard but you know
i'm not closing the door on it by any
means i still think that there's
definitely technology that's important
there i'm just extremely skeptical of
like most of what people are putting out
there it makes sense right like if you
look at influencers if you look at
social media accounts youtube channels
internet stocks like most things aren't
good
that's how the world actually works yeah
right
but when there's a brand new technology
everyone always gets cr this is just
textbook happening happen in social
networks
do you know that there was social
network bibo do you know that bibo sold
for 850 million dollars to aol yeah i
remember that
like like there was a hundred
myspaces there was 200 myspaces back in
the day early on [ __ ] is muckery that's
why this worked out and this one had a
lot of money being thrown around because
of the crypto craze so i think we're in
a better spot now i'm excited about that
uh i think it's going to be a lot a lot
healthier this next year people can be
more thoughtful they're going to want to
know who the [ __ ] running the project
are they capable everyone's like what's
the road map people would say we're
gonna do this this and this i was like
do you think they can do that
that's like pitch decks for startups i
met thousands of people in the last
decade who are like here's what my
company's gonna do and i had to say i
don't think you can do that i'm not
gonna write you a check but isn't that a
terrible part of being an entrepreneur
or being especially like somebody like
you who people want you to invest in
their projects that at a certain part
your job kind of becomes just saying no
to people over and over and over more so
than you're saying yes because there's a
lot more bad ideas than there are good
ideas it sucks but you actually start to
realize you're doing people a service
when i say no i'm not like a dick i'm
not like yo your [ __ ] sucks get the [ __ ]
out of my office i'm like hey i'm
concerned about this your customer
acquisition plan's wrong facebook ads
have changed you're gonna get caught
there have you thought about this do you
know that this guy's doing that over
like i try to give constructive thought
processes to my why
and i've had a lot of entrepreneurs over
the decade reach out to me and be like
yo
your meeting where you broke my [ __ ]
down i went back home and re-fucking did
it and it you [ __ ] helped me so i'm
proud
i prefer to say yes i don't like
negativity so like i prefer to but
you're scared to lose your own money
you're not just real life and number two
along the way i realized me giving
people rationale to why no was actually
incredibly valuable sometimes more
valuable than when i used to write
checks and kind of [ __ ] on sit on my
[ __ ] right and then they actually
haven't been like [ __ ] why didn't i you
know you you mature along the way on how
to give candace kind feedback to your no
right is there anything in this space
that we're talking about that you that
uh nfts and all that that you've missed
out on that you look back on you're like
geez i wish i was a little bit more
open-minded on that one
no because i i'm very heavy in early
stages into yes and willing to lose for
the education because i always play with
time and money that i'm willing to lose
most people play a lot of people in gold
rushes play with money they can't afford
to lose because they're convinced
they're going to 10x 100x 50x and so and
so
i'm incredibly
thoughtful about the money i'm going to
play with and then other people
like they like hold up their time as
valuable when their time's not valuable
like i'm willing to spend the time to
work i'm going to spend the money to
learn and i'm willing to deal with
everything going to zero if it doesn't
pop off so the answer is no i don't have
that regret because anything i've been
even somewhat curious about i bought
i like it that's why i think i'm gonna
get i'm gonna become a befriends guy
regardless of the face tattoo idea but
what about the face tattoo i get the
face tattoo idea is still on the table
for sure yeah
and i don't charge a lot dude i'm a
cheap [ __ ] is it low it's low for the
low low
let me ask you this yes
we just seen a big big indictment come
down young thug gunning et cetera all
getting locked up we're seeing a
situation in which you know people
who probably came up in the street to
whatever extent end up making millions
of dollars and end up in a situation
where from my perspective it looks like
this was a kind of exceedingly easy case
for the government to make against them
at some point now at with you i know
you've probably seen quite a few people
over the years that start building an
impressive business but then they're
still maybe a little too tapped in with
the streets or doing some illegal [ __ ]
on the side what would be your advice to
anybody who immediately just starts
bringing in this huge amount of money as
an entertainer or whatever and needs to
really separate themselves from stuff
that could get them thrown in prison
it's a real and you know this if it was
a black and white answer it'd be so easy
there's not a human on earth that
doesn't understand
that
on paper you want to get away from
anything that creates a vulnerability
here's the problem and and this is
when i tell you i have
zero
knowledge of anything with the ricoh
stuff especially i mean
it talked about a crusher for me like my
my deep love for gunna is off the charts
and i'm a huge fan of thug i don't know
him but
you know the reality is is that
for a lot of people and i see it with
immigrant life
your friends your family they're still
living life
you might have popped off but you've got
a humongous community that you came up
with
until like
everyone who doesn't know anything about
how people that come up from little to
make a lot it's very easy for them to
pontificate in their chair at home be
like why don't they separate them right
these are your cousins your aunts your
best friend somebody that helped you out
a [ __ ] tough situation
it's incredibly challenging and a
complex situation i'm dead when i say
i'm desperate i'm desperately hoping
that they're not in a bad spot i'm
really hope i'm really like
it's been a really tough week
for that whole like scene between that
and he and it's just been like it's like
i feel incredibly emotional for people
that are in the inner circles with that
crew because this must be one of the
toughest weeks of their life that's a
fact yeah the key thing coming on the
heels of the indictment is [ __ ] crazy
um i guess last question we are at a
weed convention
how many businesses in the cannabis
space are you involved with and where do
you think that the real opportunities
and growth are in this space uh so i'm
i'm a large investor in a company called
green street that is run by rama that's
why i'm here that's what this is all
about
underneath that rama's got a ton of
stuff we've got a brand called asterick
with juicy j which is a lot of fun to be
to be transparent i'm a non-operating
partner in green street so i'm not even
sure how many things rama has going on
i'm more of the money and i'm there for
the bat phone any time
the space overall super interesting i
grew up in the liquor business which is
regulated state by state so when
cannabis started getting legalized and
when i could see the country was finally
ready to to get over to hoop on it i was
like okay uh this is something i want to
learn so i'm still in the
learning phase
you know i'm uh i'm on the board of a
company called rib capital out of out of
canada
um so i'm really in collecting
information mode
because this is inevitable like for the
rest of our lives
like there will only be more
acceptance we will see this space take
shape in front of our eyes yeah and for
me
it's always about brands right liquid
death was started by a former creative
lead at vaynermedia
i did michael is a good good dude so
nike private like all this [ __ ] we've
been talking about so i think my destiny
long term is to be involved on the brand
side we'll see um but uh but it's a very
interesting space and obviously
it's it's
i think people forget how long the
world's been around
weed has only been a problem for less
than 100 years or about 100 years so not
been that like out of the history of
time we're just coming off the back end
where we demonized it but i think it's
going to help a lot of people with
emotional physical issues i'm excited to
see fungus and cannabis
find their appropriate place in society
and bring a lot of the benefits
i mean i hate when people like i
literally have meetings with some people
old heads who try to [ __ ] on it while
they're drinking a [ __ ] cocktail and
i'm like you do understand in 19 20 and
30 people said the same thing about
alcohol everything's [ __ ] up when it's
off balance but in balance everything
can be appropriate
and so i think i think i'm excited that
the stigma is going away and i think we
can have far healthier conversations
around it in the next decade
gary vee appreciate you we're about to
go on stage
[Music]
you